holy cow boys I call paniolo that's the
property Punic War lon
main Hawaiian is a plain slack key and
the pani Ola way of life goes together
because after a hard day's work on the
ranch you want to sit down relax and
listen to this beautiful music my name
is Liberty Lindsay and I'm the fifth
generation of the paniolo Hawaiian
cowboy and I play Hawaiian slack II
music I'm Chris funk I'm a musician in a
band called The Decemberists and I'm on
a journey looking for the most
surprising and extraordinary people in
music my next stop takes me to Waimea
Hawaii
there I will meet up a Leibert Lindsay
the unsung hero of Hawaii's Forgotten
cowboy culture
Hawaii offers so much beauty from cliffs
rising out of the ocean to rolling hills
and lush green valleys but what
surprised me when I got here was the
deep rooted community of cowboys
something normally associated with the
Southwest people they don't realize how
far back we go being Hawaiian Cowboys as
part of our heritage we had Cowboys here
on the Big Island before there was any
states west of the Mississippi including
Texas the influence of Spanish Cowboys
called Vaqueros is ever-present in
Hawaiian culture they came here in the
1800s to teach the Islanders to herd
cattle bringing with them a lasting way
of life culture and a unique style of
music called slack key I just heard you
from up there slack key style involves
loosening the string while tuning to
create a sweet soothing sound synonymous
with the Aloha nature of Hawaii when the
Vaqueros came here that they bought the
guitar along with them they brought some
open Spanish twins and they taught the
hoynes how to play these to me so I
always played it learned it and then
they created their own style of play
kilo is called its lucky
obody
the Cowboys does everything from A to Z
work the cattle brand the cattle come on
in money ole and when the job is done
they play slack key and sometimes they
play music right there where they're at
I've never seen upon iolo
without his guitar this it's like a fish
without water the authenticity of Lieber
and the pond yellows blew me away
modern-day folk music is rooted in
historical themes like coal mining and
railroad work even though today's
musicians have never likely done these
jobs but Libert embodies everything
about the lifestyle he's a true Hawaiian
cowboy who also happens to be one of the
best slack key guitarist I'm very
appreciative to the volcanoes who came
here to teach us Hawaiians
how to be Cowboys and we created our own
style of being Cowboys which is it's
something that is is really valuable in
our real life if you don't pass this
knowledge down to the next generation
it's going to be lost this is a really
really important part of our heritage
that we want to continue suppose that
called me a Hawaiian I'm not gonna say
no all right good yes funny old
[Music]